Thank you very much. It's loved.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
So thank you for giving up
your lunch hour, I believe, uh,
to come and hear me talk about my book.
And My name is Helen Scales.
I'm a marine biologist. Um, and just
in case any of you are wondering,
that is my real name scales fish. Yes. Um,
uh,
and this is my book spirals and time,
the secret life of curious
afterlife of seashells.
And I want to tell you
a little bit about how,
why I wrote the book and tell you a
few of the stories that go into it.
Um, starting off, um, all really
the title files and time, the,
the secret life of curious afterlife
of seashells. And in the review, I, uh,
I got in the Guardian
newspaper a few months ago.
Uh,
I made the mistake of reading below the
line on the website version and looking
at some of the comments people had
written and one person felt necessary to
comment on the subtitle.
The secret life of curious afterlife
was clearly a clever, clever title, uh,
provided by the publisher in forced
on this kind of popular science book.
It's the sort of tightly have
to have, um, luckily, uh,
somebody else commented also what it,
it just kind of tells you what
the book's about. That's fine. Um,
but actually it wasn't my publishers.
It was my mom who came up with the title
and subtitle and I'm really pleased he
did because, um, it means she kind of got
what the book was about. It's like she,
um, from me talking about
it for ages and, uh,
and also making a read bits
of it as it was going wrong.
She clearly kind of got what
it was I was trying to do,
even perhaps before I
really realized. Um, so yes,
there's really two
things I'm doing in book.
One is telling the story
of the lives of the shell.
Michael's the animals that make
seashells and we all know those beautiful
objective find on a beach. Um, Martin
pick them up and taking them home,
but what did they come from?
How they made what happens in the lives
of the creatures and that left these
shells behind. So I
wanted to tell Polly, uh,
the story about the wonderful creatures,
the mollusks that makes the shells. Um,
mollusks are really one of
the most strange, smart,
tough, um, ancient and successful
groups of animals on the planet.
Um,
we're talking about familiar creatures,
mollusks range from slugs and snails and
squid and octopus to slightly stranger
things.
You might not have heard of things like
argonauts and see what supplies and
Chitins and weird little things called
Selena gastros that limit the bottom of
the sea. And frankly just
looked like worms. But they
are still modest because, um,
they are one of the most diverse
groups of animals on the planet.
I'm really, they were really
beaten by the arthropods. Um,
another phylum,
these are phyla that we're talking about
to kind of bleeping within the animal
kingdom. And the arthropods
secured all the insects. Um,
so they definitely weren't
in terms of the, the,
the largest number of species within
a filer does over a million species of
insect alone.
Most of them a beetles.
But mollusks come in like a
good second place frankly. And,
and they are an incredibly strange
bunch of animals that live all sorts of
different lives.
Um,
it's thought I could be about 50 to a
hundred thousand species of Mollusk alive
today that we've
described already. Um, um,
do you have know for
sure cause there's no,
up until now there hasn't been a central
catalog to list all the names of all
the monitors that had been described
scientifically. We are now doing that.
So hopefully we will get a bit more of
a grasp on just how diversity is Amazon.
Um,
but uh,
it's thought by some of
the leading thinkers and
scientists who work on mollusks
that actually there could be more like
200,000 species including ones we haven't
discovered yet, including
creatures like these guys. Um,
so these are all micro cause they would
just gave a found in Papua New Guinea
just last summer.
They are all under five millimeters in
size about size of your little fingernail.
And none of these have been
described scientifically yet.
They've just been found.
They were found during an expedition
led by guy called Phillip,
you shade from the Natural History Museum
in Paris and he basically spends his
life going around the world leading
expeditions, trying to find as many mamas,
cause it's possible people
do this kind of thing.
Scientists focus on a group and you know,
really try and figure out what's going on.
Um,
these were all found around
coral reefs. Um, and they just,
just incredible creatures.
I mean these are types of Melissa
snails and clams that no one's ever seen
before. I mean, that was a clown with
pink tentacles. Begin the sake and,
and transparent shells and you can see
it as the skin underneath is brightly
colors.
Um,
but these particular animals and
plenty more that they find on these
expeditions, uh, remain kind
of on a, on a museum shelf.
Undescribed they're called orphan
species because we lack the expertise to
actually have people sit down and name
individual species but just don't know
enough about this kind of diversity.
Um, so there's all this headon,
this hidden side to the lives of mollusks.
That was partly what I wanted to talk
about in the book was all the things that
we don't yet know about.
This incredible group of animals,
including the species that we haven't
yet found. And um, and Phillipe,
I spoke to him and he's one of the
people who really thinks they could be
200,000 species of mollusks and a,
and he should know he's looking for them.
He's finding more and more all the time,
even if all he's really doing is doing
a headcount and this is something
different. We don't know what it is yet
and we don't know what it might contain.
We don't know how it lives,
what interesting things that
these animals might be doing.
And one of the things I really kind of
amazed me while I was writing the book,
um, right up until the point
where by publishers were like, no,
you have to stop now. You cannot
put any more signs into this book.
There's so many new discoveries are coming
out of the mollusk worlds that pretty
much every week I'd be like,
oh,
there's another cool story I want to
put in the book. Like the fact that, um,
thin pits have the toughest teeth made
out of the toughest known biological
material.
They've knocked spider silk off the perch.
And they figured that actually because
these are the snails that kept themselves
to rock and spend their lives
scraping the rock with their teeth,
they've evolved this incredibly
strong material in their teeth.
So it's like that has to go in the
book somewhere. We have to get it in.
And then I think actually just the last
thing I did manage to get in the book,
the last story was, um,
about how cone snails,
these are poisonous sees now that live
in the tropics and they are kind of
notorious for having incredibly diverse
and complex toxins that they used to
hunt all sorts of animals,
including fish.
And there are a few species
that if they sting a human,
they will actually kill them.
A bit of an overkill,
but there's reasons why we think they're
such powerful computers so that they
can actually a tiny snail that slowly
slides along the seabed has the ability to
eat fast moving fish,
which is kind of incredible.
And a new discovery just came out a few
months before the book came out. Um,
that they in fact use insulin as part of
their weaponry so that the only animal
we know that's kind of
evolved this hormone.
So that essentially knocked out
its prey by giving it a dent,
a dose of insulin so that their blood
sugar levels drop and they faint and they
can then eat these fish.
And that's just really cool.
So there were lots of
incredible, cool, um,
amazing mind blowing discoveries coming
out of the vonner squirrelled. Um,
and that was a really big part of what
I wanted to do with the book was to
capture this excitement of what we're
discovering and the applications of a lot
with this.
This sciences is kind of exciting to the
cone snail veterans that have been used
to develop medicines that have been
used in biomedical research. Um,
the fact that razor clams, I don't know
if you've ever seen a long thing, um,
shells you might see on a beach.
They borrow themselves in the sand,
but they're much more efficient to
doing it then, then just their muscles.
And the shape of this, the strength
of their shell would suggest. Um,
and um,
researchers have figured out that they
actually have this clever technique of
creating little pools of
quicksand around one mistake,
dig down and it's incredibly
efficient way of Berry of borrowing.
And um,
this could lead to the next generation of,
of underwater robots that can now fix
things to the seabed even and sort of
undersea cables for the Internet.
It could be being fixed down by these
dog robots inspired by razor clams.
So there's tons of cool
stuff about Valascus that I
was trying to talk about in
the book. And um, and some of the,
what I wanted to capture too with some
of the big discoveries and some of the
big questions that scientists have
thought about when it comes to shells and
mollusks, um, over the years.
And one of the big ones is
the shape of their shells.
How is it that Shell's on made?
They've got these,
many of them are beautiful spirals.
I called my book spirals in time.
I guess cause I wanted to earlier to the
idea that these things have been around
for a long time and spiraling around
these carbonate spirals have been,
I've been around for probably
for half a billion years.
We think mollusks first evolved in the
oceans about 500 million years ago. Um,
how do they make their shells and why
are there so many different shapes?
And then lots of great thinkers have put
their mind to trying to work out what
is the mathematics that light
behind shells and shall making, um,
one of the simplest parts of a shell
of a mollusk aspiring to them is the
logarithmic spiral and spiral that
expands at a constant rate. Um,
it was when I Descartes who came
up with this idea of a log spiral.
And if you cut through a chambered
Nautilus, which is this shell here,
and you get a pretty good
approximation to that,
that logarithmic spiral into dimensions.
And if you look at lots of
different mollusks, uh, lots of,
many of the guests reports
with the spiraling shells,
the snails as well as these,
the Nautilus is and various other,
the bivalves two clans and so on,
they do,
they do still have spirals in their
shells. We'll come to that. Um,
what about in three dimensions?
That was the next big question.
That's that scientists were thinking
about mathematicians and philosophers
wanted to figure out how could you make
a three dimensional shouts all very well
to say you've got these two dimensions.
The locks viral is really
important actually because, um,
the matter how big or small it is,
it's the same shape.
And that is a key rule to making shells.
Is that that tiny or if they're huge,
they um, because they, uh,
they will stay the same shape.
So mosques keep their shells that whole
lives unlike crustacean the crabs and
lobsters which shed their shells and
brought new ones mollusks keep the same
ones and just growing bigger and
bigger, but they stay the same. Um,
they stayed the same shape. People
if they're tiny or huge. Um,
but how about three dimensions? Um, so
it was, um, if turn of the 20th century,
there was a guy called Darcy went with
Thompson who wrote a book called on
growth and formed and,
and he was really thinking about shapes
in nature and how can mathematics
described the shapes of a splash or a
dia is Adler or indeed the shape of a
three dimensional inspiring Chubb. And
he came with the idea that perhaps, um,
you create these three d shales by
spinning a two dimensional shape in three
dimensions. Um, so essentially what he's
looking at is having like a central axis,
okay. That pictures, um,
around which may be a circle,
a flat circle spins around and it can
either do so in the same plane or it can
drop down that, that access. It can, um,
the wiles of the show can
overlap each other or not.
And perhaps it would only take
three m this is running away,
um,
three or four simple rules to actually
make all the different channels that you
see in nature. So he came up with
this idea, just a theoretical idea.
He couldn't test it.
All he had was paper and Pencil.
Could you make all of the shelves we
see in nature with three simple rules of
this single circle spinning
through three dimensions,
how tall it gets along the access,
and how,
how much those worlds overlap each other.
These ideas we'll pick top or 40 years
later by a paleontologist called David
route. Um, who did something
unusual for a paleontologist. Um,
certainly at the time he used a computer
and he took these equations from
Thompson and he plugged
them into a mainframe.
Ibm 1790 computer. There's sort
of thing that was at the time,
this was an in the 60s,
50s and 60s was intended to be used for
designing aircraft and nuclear reactors,
but I think he managed to get some time
downtime. Um, he was at Johns Hopkins,
University of Maryland, um,
and he used this computer to,
to build shells and to see if these,
um,
these simple rules that
Thomson had come up with,
whether you really could make all the
different styles that you see in three
dimensions. And, um, and he did,
I mean the output he had from his computer
work where it was all kind of two d
plots, which would then realize
by an artist in three dimensions.
But we can now have a look at kind of a,
a mock up of what the output of
his model would have looked like.
And I'm to let that run. I think it's
incredibly beautiful and mesmerizing.
So what we're doing here is just
changing these parameters, the heights,
the expansion,
the rate at which the
shelf flares open as well.
And just by changing
these three parameters,
you do actually get an
incredible diversity of shells
emerging from those simple
rules. That's incredible. Yeah. This,
the diversity of shells can be explained
through fairly simple mathematic.
You get the clan from a spiraling Shelly,
you wouldn't expect that,
but it kind of pops up.
And,
and what route did was he created?
What's come to be known as the Museum
of all possible shells and populated by
these shells created from this is lower
than that, these, these equations.
And,
um,
and what seem to be all these different
endless forms that you see in nature.
But the really surprising thing he found
was that the museum of all possible
shells actually isn't full of real shells.
If you look at the shells that
have actually evolved, um,
in the past through fossils and
through, um, uh, what's it like today?
There are lots of parts of this space if
you think about it as being this actual
space with those three parameters on
each song. The next one is that access.
There are large parts of this space that
aren't occupied and those shells have
evolved and it's very,
it's raised this question about, um, uh,
this is a theory called, um,
sort of theoretical morpho space.
The possibilities of what organisms
could be and what shapes they can be and
what they actually are and why
there's a difference between the two.
So evolution hasn't taken mollis cause
shells to all the possibilities that the,
um,
the simple rules could,
could lead to some of these
shelves just haven't existed,
not pointed out to some of them.
Once he made in his computer,
wouldn't have worked there
or clams that wouldn't open.
There are some that would just be
kind of flimsy and they wouldn't be
competitive, um, out there in the wild,
in the wild ocean and in
places where molluscs live.
But there are plenty of shuttles that
seemed to be perfectly good and there
seems no reason why they haven't evolved
and there's people have expanded this
idea out now and we've built
museums of possible possible, um,
fish and plants and all different types
of organisms that you can look at them
or follow it and see what could be,
what potential shapes they could be and
then compare that to what we actually
see. And again, and again, you see
this limit of what is creators,
what evolution has thrown up and,
and what potentially could occur and,
and discussions are going on.
Like there is this division between some
people who think that ultimately, yes,
all these shelves could and would
evolve if the situation arose.
That's that shell would be well
adapted to a particular condition.
And there are others who
think that actually maybe no,
then that's the evolution.
Genetically there isn't the material
that would ever evolve these shelves.
I just wouldn't ever happen.
Um, and the discussions go on.
So that's one of the big questions or
look into in a bit more detail in the book
of,
of how shells evolve,
why they're different shapes and why
we don't actually see all the potential
shells that mathematics suggest
could exist in the world.
So that's the life part of the subtitle.
Um,
there's also the afterlife and um,
this isn't the bit of the book where I
talk about snail ghosts or any kind of
belief in the afterlife.
It's really just my desire to talk about,
uh,
how humans have used shells.
So after the animals inside that made
them died in long gone and they've left
behind these empty shells.
Um,
we do all sorts of things with them
and there's incredible long history,
pretty much to the dawn of humanity
that people have seen shells.
They found them and put
them to all sorts of uses,
practical and incredibly deep
symbolism and meaning and seashells.
Um,
I was really amazed researching the book,
just how broad and how universal
these beliefs in shells are there.
Symbols of sex and death and birth and,
and power and money and cultures
all over the world and even far,
far from the ocean and have these
incredibly strong beliefs. And Charles,
so I'm going to tell some of those
stories and I partly wanted to try and
reinstate some of the
grander and some of the, um,
the wander and magnificence of shells
in human hives because today I think
shells have kind of got more of a
reputation for being fairly kind of bad,
cheap, throwaway trinkets, their emblems
of the ocean that we can buy, you know,
buy from a seaside stall or
perhaps we can find them ourselves.
We don't maybe pay them that much
attention and people make things like,
um, there we go. That's the kind of
thing people use salesforce these days.
Um, and we make things like this.
And also this, which is true,
this was on site, found this on
sale on Ebay. She's got lovely,
lovely headdress on the her
all day running around. Um,
so I basically just wanted to,
I what I wanted to do is,
was tell stories of how people have used
shells in the past in ways that it far
more magnificent.
So this guy here is about 7,000 years old.
I don't know why does this morning star,
I'm going to just hang on a second.
Let us do this a different way so it
just stops, stops going too quickly.
Um,
so yeah,
I wanted to tell stories of how people
have used towels not to make comedy frogs.
So next. Um, so this is, uh,
this is a great founder in Bulgaria.
Um, and uh, about 7,000 years
old time of old, you didn't,
it's cool.
They're called the old Europeans.
Then you wonder why it's
doing that auto advance on
it doesn't matter.
I want to tell you what I can do,
what I can put up the pdf and
use the pdf. Yeah, thanks. Sorry.
Okay,
excellent.
Sorry. Um, yes.
Stories of shows been using
human lives that's um, this,
this incredibly rich history of, of, of
the beliefs and the symbolism of shale.
So this, this, um, chat is the
leader of the Wianno community.
These guys lived in Europe for about
7,000 years ago up until this point when
this was discovered in the 1970s, this
grave in a, in a city of the dead,
um,
in Bulgaria.
It was still that the Europeans were
quite in the gutter Terrian group and that
they were mostly just,
um, nomadic farmers.
That was their sign up until that point,
have any elites who are kind of in charge
and that society was fairly even an
equal. And then they find a grave
with a guy covered in gold and, uh,
with all sorts of jewelry, uh, including
some very beautiful shall jewelry.
And that's why I want to talk
about this particular case. Um,
around this guy's upper arm.
You can see on one side he's got
bangles and commuting a white one.
And that's made from a
shell called spawn diagnose.
It comes from a long way from this part.
It wasn't coming from the Black Sea,
but from the Mediterranean. And, um,
and there was this long
distance trade in the shells,
correspond spondylitis that were
carved into beautiful objects, um,
all the way across Europe to Paris.
And I know from what was done with them
was they were carved into bangles at
people wore. Um, and it, there's even
been studies to show you that, um,
some of these bangles are put onto
people's arms when they were children and
then they, they drew into them
and can take them off again. Um,
this particular one there
was just really intriguing.
So it was carved from this big shell,
these big spot in apple spiny oysters.
It's another name for these shelves.
Then in life, they're covered in spines,
but cut them through and they've got
this beautiful bright white home show and
coughed into a bangle roquette's kits
and then fixed it with gold plates.
Um, and that's what this guy's wearing
and we don't know why they did that.
Spurious others,
this is very solid.
The remains that seem to have been
deliberately broken of these shows, um,
left in graves. So there's some
significance behind this particular,
this particular show was always the same
species that was being used and then it
just disappeared. And they stopped being
used at this about 6,000. He's got,
and that's it. No more spondylitis. Um,
there was a parallel trade in spawn of
shells in the Americans with the Aztecs,
the Mayans, they were using spawn dollar
sales, fall decorations and money. Um,
they were carving statuettes of humans,
giving them to children and taking them
to the tops of the highest mountains and
leaving them there as human sacrifices.
So there were all these incredible
significant stories about shells.
So I tell some of those
stories in the book, um,
and hopefully kind of try to
William State some of the,
the sense of mystery and wonder
about what watch hell's are.
And I think one of the reasons people
value them so much is because they come
from this doc, uh, deep
ocean where, you know,
full of sea monsters
and things we can't see.
But these beautiful objects washed up on
beaches and people have always wondered
why they come from and how they're made
and holding them. Great three meeting.
So,
uh
Oh no,
I'm breaking the time.
Sorry.
That's fine.
And so it wasn't,
uh,
the beliefs and the kind of symbolism
and mysteries of shells have an all just
died out in the past. There's plenty of,
of modern thank you very much. Security.
Um,
there are still some,
some one stories in modern of
of shelves fitting that role of,
of some mysterious objects surrounded by
sort of significant beliefs and ideas.
And, and I followed the story of one
of them in the modern world today.
If this stuff could see
silk silk from the seat.
And lots of ancient stories have been
told about this stuff called [inaudible],
which comes from a shell
called the noble Penn Shell.
It was crazy in the Caribbean,
in the Mediterranean,
they can go talk to a meter tall.
They look like giant muscles,
just like a muscle that you would eat.
They stand really tall
and this stuff called CSO,
it comes from the threads that they
make to anchor themselves to the seabed.
If you've ever eaten muscles or had
cooked them a breathing muscles,
you will probably have to bid them and
put young cows the a fibers. That's that.
They have same stuff.
I mean these shells have really big ones
cause they been bigger and they have to
use that there. And biceps threads,
which I'll come back to, to, to,
to anchor themselves solidly into
the, don't get swept away. Anyway.
So there's lots of stories told
about Cecil also known as basis. Um,
there are stories told of the
ancient Egyptians varied there,
pharaohs and wrapped in cloth made of see,
Soak.
Henry the eighth had a picnic for the
king of France with his men all dressed in
golden.
See soap.
And the stories go on and on the stories
in the Bible of [inaudible]. Um, and,
and a lot of people do still
believe that the, you know,
this has a very ancient origin. Maybe
thousands of years ago. And I went to,
uh, to southern, yeah.
To find and to meet the lady who
calls herself the last Maestro Fci.
So can, she says she's the
only person left in the world.
He knows how to weave fabric
and threads from this,
this fiber lady called Chiara Vigo.
Um,
there was a story in the BBC
couple of days ago about her. Um,
it might seen it on the BBC website,
check it out.
That gives one side of the
story, which is interesting, um,
about what she goes up to.
And she has a museum of business advisors
museum and a tiny island of Sardinia
called some kind of yoga where
she does she practices. We even,
she shows people how
this is done. And, um,
we tells all these stories about isis
and see sort of going back into the Bible
and beyond thousands years ago.
Um,
but as I was researching
and working on the book,
I met and spent a lot of time with,
um, a few people who actually study.
Cecil can look at them. Um,
the, the academic side of it.
And scholars have tried,
have traced records of sea salt back in,
back in the literature back into the
past and discovered that there's a big
problem with this story that Cecil
silk is such an ancient stuff. Um,
and, and really it comes down
to a spelling mistake about, um,
well in the 15th century,
a lot of talk about sea salt goes back
to Aristotle's book on the history of
animals and he talks
about Penn shells and, um,
how, uh, they have these, these,
these fibers coming out to
them called [inaudible].
And therefore sea salt comes
from Penn shells and it's, uh,
it's connected to this work basis. Um,
but actually what the truth of it is,
is that word basis was never
connected to Penn shells.
When Aristotle originally
wrote those books,
it was a translation much later that miss
translated a word that means deep and
depth. The word that leads us to
things like, um, at this, um, and um,
bathysphere so word for deep,
what he was originally saying was that
these shells grown the deep water. And,
um, and that was that, that's
why he used the word biceps.
And a translation came along, um, in
Latin later on in the 15th century,
shifted an accent from one word of,
I think it actually from the Greek,
from one letter to another and
changed it from meaning deeper too,
meaning fine cloth.
And from then on by Isis was associated
with fine cloths and there is a word by
isis that means linens and cottons
and all sorts of fine fabrics but not
specifically.
But once that translation kicked in and
it was a really popular translation of
that book by Aristotle,
everyone thought that by Isis,
whenever it was mentioned back in,
in all of the old texts refers to CSUMB
and it doesn't, it just means fine,
plump. So unfortunately all this talk
about Cecil being this ancient stuff,
it doesn't really have any foundation,
but no one really is listening to
these scholars who were saying,
have you actually looked and seen
that there is this mistake and we're,
we're actually telling stories that
aren't true. But that doesn't stop. Um,
a certain lady continuing to show people
this and that's fine. I went to see her,
she was very pleasant and she
showed me what she was doing.
But when I was in Santiago,
I also met, Uhm, okay,
that's a lump of law by service before
it's been processed as it's been pulled
off the shelf,
it's got little bits of seashell in it.
And that freeness shop is
a piece of process by Isis.
The Cecil before she leaves it,
um, I met these ladies who also,
so we've see so soon.
Chiara is not the only one.
She claims to be the maestro. But there
are some other people who still do it.
And these lovely ladies show me the same
process, how, how they card the fibers,
how they spin them and then use them
to, we've um, uh, embroideries I guess.
And the problem, one of the problems is
that the pen shells and are protected.
There are protective species cause for
various reasons they're not doing very
well. They live in sea grass beds, um,
which just suffering from things like
climate change and habitat destruction.
So they've been protected and you're
not allowed to actually take them.
It's illegal to take these shells.
What harm limit any way.
Kiarra claims that she has found a a
way of sustainably harvesting CSUMB from
Shell's, uh, by taking them up and snip
threads and then putting them back.
Um,
the problem is that she's so surrounded
in secrecy and what she does that no one
is allowed to go with her
while she's doing this. Um,
and so I can't comment as to whether she's
actually doing this sustainably or if
she's up to something else because she
absolutely refused for me to go with her
and see what she was up
to. Um, the other ladies,
this is the picture of these two groups,
these guys,
these guys just subpoena and Asam, Tina
Pez, we're very open and said to me,
you know, we can't get hold of many more
fibers. We can't do this new anymore.
They had a little collection of it that
their grandmother had given them and
they use it to show people like me who
wants to just want to see how it's done.
Mostly that mostly they just use other
fibers these days and carry on with their
traditional weavings,
but not with CSOS.
And occasionally a fisherman will find a
dead shell and give it to them and they
have a bit more to use. But then like,
you know, it's a thing of the past.
We want to remember how it's done,
but we can't pretend that we can still
do it because these shells just aren't
available. Um, and I just got this very,
I felt like when I was
reporting on the story,
this was not what I was expecting at all.
I was just expected to tell a simple story
of this strange old fiber that's been
here since the Bible and kind of found
I was getting sucked into the stranger
story than I expected of, of things
not being quite as they should see.
So it was really fun.
So how are we doing for time?
Excellent. A question. I
often get asked by people,
mostly kids, but then they
always asked the best questions.
And when I'm talking about Cheryl's
and molluscs and my book is what's my
favorite shell and what's my
favorite mollusk um, so I tell them,
that's a really hard question. You do
know that there might be 200,000 species.
Um, but okay, if you make me, I will tell
you that my favorite is the argonaut.
I even have it on my teachers
that's helping with, um, and uh,
there's a couple of reasons why I do
genuinely think that organoids are
brilliant, brilliant.
Mollusks. Um, firstly,
all they are the only
octopus that have shells.
So up to pursue the other mollusks
that generally have, um, evolved.
Like for that Michelle, they'd
have a soft life. They're very,
have evolved other mechanisms to survive
and to do kind of be well without
having an external shell.
But argonauts still have shells.
I can just about make out. So this
is, it's, they also go paper Nautilus.
They're not related to the chambered
nautilus and you look a little bit like it
and they have this paper, Rochelle, um,
and then the octopus slips and sunlight
and they're very beautiful creatures.
I've never seen one myself.
Um,
they live in the open ocean and
they're really hard to find them.
You have to really just
find the shells washed up.
But I'm no living creature inside.
And for a long time,
the big question was there were these
kind of sort of gentlemanly arguments and
debates among the scientists,
certainly the Victorian
Times about the true,
the truth behind [inaudible] and whether
or not they make their own towns or
whether they steal them from some other
animal that we haven't yet discovered.
Um,
this was the likes of Richard Oh,
in the guy who set up the
natural history museum. Um,
he was really keen to figure
out whether argonauts where,
what shall makers or basically pirates
that stock shelves, Monica creatures.
And they were just really a
story is told and all sorts of,
I think Aristotle told stories about
this and um, about argonauts, um,
I think he started it all off
actually by claiming to have seen, um,
argonauts using their shells as little
boats. So I haven't got one to tell you,
but Tom,
they are quite hollow and lights and you
can imagine that they would float along
the surface of the sea.
And he told stories of seeing these
little octopus sitting inside there,
but in their shells, um, and
sticking to have their tentacles,
which one of them you can see here, they
do spread out into this white men range.
We'll come back to,
but he recommend they put them in the
air as sales and they caught the breeze.
They drifted around in their little boats
or boats or other scientists claimed
to have seen argonauts using their arms
as Rohan to run solve along again on the
steps of the seat with that all boats.
So, um, and the story gets told them,
told if you read 20,000 leagues
under the sea by Joe Van,
he tells the story about how Professor
Eran acts at one point pops up onto the
nautilus. Haha. There's the nautilus,
there's a name again. Actually.
It's quite sweet. The, um, uh,
and he sees, uh, they see, uh,
a raft of, of argonauts drifting past.
It seems to go from a five minutes.
Um, and um, uh,
and yeah, with the is the is which
the sales supposedly drifting along.
Um, and it's his butler. At
one point you pointed out,
I don't know if you know the story of
20,000 Leagues under the sea and how it's
Captain Nemo, who's this
kind of crazy, um, um,
Marriner who kidnaps the scientists
and takes him around the world, um,
in the nautilus, which is just
suffering. Um, and there's, uh,
there is some scientific truth, a lot
of the stuff that he writes about us.
What was the science at the time we
knew about, um, that's your van was,
it was really a marine biology book,
but kind of with a story,
which is quite nice. And,
um, professor Aaron Acts,
the Marine Biologists
assistant actually says, well,
why didn't captain Nimo call
his ship the Arbonne naught?
Because,
um,
argonauts the optimists can actually
come all the way out of the shell.
Unlike an autonomous, which is
like a snail, you can take it out.
It would immediately not be very, well if
you tried to put us near like Michelle,
but the optimists can leave their
shells, but they just choose not to. Um,
and Captain Nemo was kind of the
same. He could leave his, um,
he could leave his submarine be,
chooses not to.
He lives forever beneath the waves,
kind of an exile from humanity.
So I thought that was quite nice.
There was a point about,
it's like you should have called it
the up the arm and or not Nautilus. Um,
so yeah,
so this debate went on about
our do argonauts make their
shells or do they steal
them?
And the other reason why really wanting
to tell the story of I'm not some why
they're brilliant is because of this
lady who finally cracked this question of
the truth about argonauts.
Um, her name's John John.
We've her power and she
was French and married, um,
a Sicilian Sicilian. He, she
went to, lived in Sicily, um,
as a lady of leisure. She
started off life as a poor, um,
in a little village in France,
but ended up meeting this
guy and get married and spent
the rest of her life, um,
as a scientist,
like basically it's a lady of leisure
that she decided that she wanted to go out
and just explore the world.
She explores this lady.
She did lots of studies of the animals
of the island. She sounds a bit like a,
a latter day. Gerald Durrell, she brought
things to live in a house with her.
There were pine Martins running around
and, but, but one of the things she did,
and she actually isn't very
well remembered for and
why I want to write about
her story is that she, she pioneered some
Incredibles marine biological studies,
um, and invented it, um, an aquarium tank
for research. And she built this thing,
um,
which kind of was just made of words.
It was an open box with wooden slats
that let's see water come through.
And she would anchor it at the edge of
the sea and she would take argonauts that
fishermen would catch for her and
she would occasionally catch herself.
And she placed him in these,
in these observation chambers.
And she conducted some really
quite elaborate experiments
on them to figure out,
okay, do they make shells or do they
borrow them from something else or do they
parasitize and other animal. And, um,
and I give the details of experiments in
the book and there's a really brilliant
idea. Some of them are a bit cruel, you
know, you have to do things like brake,
Argonaute shells and see if they can
fix them, take their shells away.
And she slowly built up this picture
that really did convincing each show that
Arbonne awesome. Yes, they
do make their own entails.
And in fact it's the females that do.
Um,
and the males are just
were nowhere to be seen,
but it was always the females she
found when making these shelves.
And in fact this, um, the
membrane that you see on the,
um, on the outside of start,
that's what makes the show.
It's really different to the other
molluscs which have this thing called a
mantle, which covers all of their
body and that's what makes the shell,
whereas they have a modified the
end of two tentacles and they,
it looks kind of silvery when
you see them alive and they, um,
they can fix up patches in a shelf.
It's broken.
And they also make the show initially
they only have to make one shell,
like the rest of the mollusks.
Uh, so if they, if they,
if they're parted from that
Shell, um, they don't survive,
which I guess is what I think
always hang on to them. Um,
so she started having ideas.
Um,
we are pro power did have ideas about
why were the males that she didn't quite
get to the bottom of it.
The females make these shells,
they lay their eggs inside the shells
and use them as a brood chamber, um,
but wearing pants and it wasn't till much
later it was discovered that the males
are tiny, tiny, small, um,
and basically kind of
parasitize the female. Um,
and they have one tentacle with a
packet of sperm on the end of which they
looked at her and it sticks to her body
and she can collect a few of them and
put them inside her shell and carry them
around until she's ready to fertilize
her eggs.
Um,
so the males kind of having
mother different problems
in life and the female, um,
and still things we're finding out
new things about argonauts recently,
one guy in Australia found some
live ones and discovered that, um,
they actually use their chamber,
their shelves as a buoyancy aid,
but like chambered nautilus is
they have air inside their shows,
which they use to keep
them floating on the water.
So it's a bit easier for
them to swim. And, um,
nautilus is do argonauts
to a similar thing.
He saw them basically if we emptied
all the air out of their shells,
they all would swim straight back to
the surface gulp in some air into their
shell and then spin back down until
they were neutrally buoyant at the depth
they wanted to live.
So it kind of reduces their costs of
swimming by having a bubble of air inside.
It's like kind of underwater blimp,
which is really cool.
And leads me to my final thing I
wanted to talk to you about, which, um,
takes me back to the title of the book.
And also I want to tell you a
little bit about, um, the artwork,
which I absolutely love. And, um,
really just so pleased with the way
the book has come out and how it looks.
And it all comes down to this
picture of an [inaudible]. Um,
it was around the time I was writing
the Argonaute chapter that I'm,
my publishers.
I published [inaudible] said that I
really had to decide what I was going to
call the book, uh, cause we had
to come up with another title,
which early on we decided we didn't
like what's going to call it snails,
tears and fund the stones.
Um,
and then everyone said the don't know
what's under stones are and what's this
thing about snails death. I think
spectator if you want. But anyway,
we decided that was no good,
but I was so obsessed with argonauts and
I was writing this chapter with all of
the great stuff that she discovered.
And um, this all the city's stories, um,
all I can see where I'm going on.
So that was my kind of five year in life.
So I wanted to call the book
flight of the Argonauts, um,
especially with this discovery of how
they use air to help them swim underwater.
Um,
and so,
and I was hunting around a
line for pitchers of argonauts
and I found this one,
um, and spine, um,
an industry to call Tara and John Gregory
had liberty's websites and not only
did he sell tee shirts with these
island, which was really cool. Um,
it turns out that he's in a band
called giant squid. Um, we got into it,
he lives in San Francisco and we got in
touch and he'd just been on holiday to
one of the islands off of California
and he'd found an organ or shell on the
beach.
We'd have to have this guy,
he's a marine biologist by
training and was retreat,
has just finished retraining
as a fine artist. So he was,
as Geeky is as Geeky as I am
about all the marine creatures.
It's like we have to have him to do the
front cover artwork because we were also
looking for,
for who we wanted to work with on that
as well as the title of the book at this
time.
So we got in touch with him and I'm
really pleased that he agreed to kind of
immediately to work with
us, which is fantastic. Um,
and I don't think he quite knew what he's
letting himself in for because we were
still undecided about the title and
I was still pushing for flight to the
argonauts, so we were like, go and do
some argonauts. So he does some sketches.
I'm going to show you some of the
sketches that he gave centers, um,
an unseen before,
since it's very exciting,
but anyone apart from me and my
public. So, um, so first of all,
he gave us some sort of tentatively,
I'm on the naughty ones
and I think they're great.
And I was really just so keen to have
flights to the arms of knots on the front
cover. But no, we decided that no
one would think that it wasn't all,
it wasn't a book about argonauts this
just a bit of it. So we had to return,
think of it,
a different title and it was literally
coming down to the last minute of like,
can we just have another day to
decide what the title's going to be?
And I kept on coming up with
ideas that we're working. Um,
and then I went on holiday to Devin and
spend a few days mocking around on the
seashore and finding shells
and having a nice time.
And then spirals and time just
popped up and I thought about the,
and everyone else seemed to like it. So
we stopped with spirals and time. Um,
and that actually meant for the cover
that we then had a whole free rein of what
we can put on the front cover of the
book. Um, I should say that I really am,
I really appreciated having a chance
to be involved in the sign in the front
cover cause I don't think authors
don't always have that opportunity.
If my first book I was just told,
here's your cover, whereas bloom spirit,
we're keen to have me
involved and I really,
it's been really fun
to have to sort of be,
be a part of the way it looks as
well as the worst and side. Um,
so I told Erin,
so the two things I wanted to have on
the front cover where lots of different
species of Mollusk,
um,
I wanted to try and capture this idea
of them being this incredibly diverse
group and also want them to be alive.
One thing again that I really want to
do with the book is to show people that
Shell's aren't just these boring
dead things that, you know,
sit around doing nothing.
They come from these incredible living
creatures that live extraordinary lives.
So I wanted living diverse
mosques all over the cover.
So the first sketchy came up with
was this, um, uh, which we'd like to,
that you can just make that out and
was moved to the laser mollusks uh,
but Jim Martin way the term is like,
nope,
too many mollusks cut
it down to confusing.
How about a spiral of bollocks.
The Tajness Byron at times we could
have a spiral. Brilliant idea.
So we said go dose a spiral.
So Aaron did this,
a couple of spirals get to is do you
want it download page or do you want to
coming out as happier? Of course
I wanted to coming out at me. Um,
we then sort of said that's really
pale, but be basically said, yeah,
I'm a big spiral going across both
covers he um, pen, pencil, sketch.
He then, this is really
interesting because, um,
I didn't know how art is done these days,
but apparently what he did was he painted
these in with ink and a paintbrush by
hand and then he called in on a computer.
So he used a tablet to do
with coloring in afterwards.
I after scanning in the inks and then
came up with some color options and we
decided to which one we it. And ultimately
that was wonderful. And I just love it.
I think it's brilliant. Um, some
of the other things he did didn't,
he did it, this administration
at the beginning of each chapter.
So I just want to quickly show you those.
So he would give us, I would say, okay,
the chapter about cone snails.
We want a nice active cone
now and catching a fish.
And then he thinks those things as well.
Um,
tucked her about see butterflies,
these beautiful sea snails,
that microscopic animals that fly through
the open ocean whole chapter about
those.
So he did us a beautiful wedding image,
should have a seat
butterflies and then um, oh,
I'm an [inaudible] but actually
that's the top two with the argonauts.
And they talk also about the
ancient extinct mollusks.
And this is power pursues the are the
biggest ammonite that we did like three
meters across. And the little shock
there is to give you scale. Um,
so did some beautiful images.
And then finally,
I'm really pleased that the
book can you get the hard,
but if you do grab a coffee,
um,
the any plates side once this from
my first book, but they said no,
but I really wanted to have beautiful
sails on the beginning and the end.
So I said we wanted went will trap snails
because they've got these incredible
complex shells. So Aaron did a little
skit and then that's what it looks like.
So if you do have a
private copy hard back,
you have snails about life size
calling over the front and back,
copied her back cover. So
they do. Thank you very much.
[inaudible].